voilà c'est parti 17 heures 39 minutes
et 50 secondes bonsoir à tous
vous rentrez du boulot ok bon ça y est
c'est bien de celle arrivée voilà la
preuve que c'est un vrai direct est la
preuve que l'on atteint un invité qui a
de l'humour
au moins je suis je suis en bonne je
suis
pascal je suis en bonne compagnie avec
le président el kabbaj qui a eu droit
aussi
oui et à la vie des gens n'a plus aucune
donnée at oui on va le message pascal ce
qu'on peut se dire aussi ce qu'on peut
se dire aussi c'est que c'est le signe
d'une véritable reconnaissance
médiatique
on peut me donner un os de google voilà
voilà voilà
regardez bien sandrine 126ème sandrine
voilà vous allez viens on va faire
sentir et à les y voilà bonsoir à tous
en tout cas merci pour votre accueil
c'était pas vrai lui on n'avait pas
prévu de démarrer les missions comme ça
mais c'est ouais la caméra là la caméra
est juste ici le petit écran de retour
et il est là je disais donc que vous
rentrez du boulot vous rentrez les cours
on va passer 35 minutes comme chaque
soir en compagnie d'un pascal sevran est
ce qu'on a là quelques combats mais
récents donnent je voudrais dire deux
choses
oui j'ai été piégé cette semaine par
surprise surprise je viens d'être piégés
par la télévision belge
et là les amis que tu avec moi m'ont dit
j'ai vraiment on est bien en belgique et
ça va je suis toujours bien reçus et un
de mes amis m'a dit fais gaffe parce que
c'est légal il ya le mec avec les tartes
à la crème au génie pas trois fois dans
la même semaine
et bien c'est complètement réussi sauf
que ja on leur a quand même un peu plus
prévoir bref c'est emmerdant pour la
chemise la faire engueuler après parce
que je vais faire une télévision tout à
l'heure je vais essayer de changer le
temps qu'on travaille un peu plus haut
on va vous dire la vérité parce qu'alors
on avait
grande de ceux qui sont fermés ou rooney
mélange est célèbre on avait imaginé que
nos amis entarter puisse peut-être sévir
durant cette semaine on a détruit et moi
on avait pris quelques dispositions mais
le problème c'est qu'ils deviennent très
très professionnel vous savez que notre
amie hélène et bien a subi les foudres
des lanceurs c'est une scène carrément
sur la scène dont vraiment y'a rien à je
comprends ces gens là je prends ça avec
je prends ça comme un hommage formidable
à ma notoriété c'est seulement ce qui
m'ennuie le plus c'est que je déteste la
crème chantilly
oui alors alors on va essayer de
remédier à ça le 19 322 502 attendait
schéma avancé je vais aller récupérer
tournoi reprend de nec je viens vers de
la up
voilà voilà qu'est ce que vous avez
besoin de quoi d'autre encore pascal
houle et qu'on cherche une v une chemise
laisse une cravate je vais aller le
temps qu'on envoie reportage met alors à
temps le tuer ce que tu veux me tenir le
micro bien sûr avait avec plaisir je
disais donc à la 19 322 2 502 27-25 ça
c'est le numéro de téléphone que vous
devrez composer ce qu'on peut récupérer
la grèce que s'il vous plaît voilà up
très bien vu j'ai suivi le quoi tous les
gens à qui c'est arrivé et vous doutez
bien que ça allait nous arriver un jour
quand même alors en plus c'est bon pour
les photographes une fois d'ailleurs à
gala il se régale
une fois que je serai débarbouiller j'en
garderai un souvenir de gloire immense
ça va aller lui attendait regardez
regardez bien ont-ils bastia je vous
faire ça au pis si cela si vous n'aimez
pas la crème chantilly effectivement ça
ne m'empêchera pas de revenir en
belgique
oui je suis toujours extrêmement bien
l'applaudît est bien accueillie
et j'espère ça ne m'empêchera pas de
revient dans nos traditions aussi sachez
qu'on était pour une fois quand vous
recevez les popstars par les gardes du
corps oui oui mon ami vous savez je
pense qu'on aurait pu avoir 25 gardes du
corps ça les aurait pas empêché de sévir
déjà partis mais ils sont très très bon
en tout cas là vous avez une facettes de
l'humour belge vous allez avoir une
autre facette maintenant de l'humour de
nos copains belge mais je dis ça
sérieusement plus parce que je trouve ça
relativement drôle en fait presque il
faut quand même ainsi qu'aux jerry hall
à la crème chantilly oui mais sinon je
me demande à l'instant même
comment je vais aller faire une
télévision à lille à poil marquer ça
fera de l'audience
en tout cas le portrait d'un belge
maintenant qu'ils pratiquent depuis 35
ans un métier vraiment pas comme les
autres se son métier ce n'est pas en
tartre heures puisque josé est le grand
spécialiste de la fauche devant
l'éternel mais ce n'est pas un
malfaiteur parce que josé il a décidé de
se ranger du bon côté on change pascal
sevran a déjà prévu la chemise aller
là-haut pour lens le reportage 3 minutes
30 pour se changer